Frankie was your idea and obviously I
ranked this little beauty before I knew
there was a dimension jump in
Psychopaths in the mix hey youtubers
it's Charlie this week on agents of
shield it is happy pranks giving we get
an advance listen in Melinda may as well
as advance multi-dimensional Facebook
stalking and somehow it all ends up in
Harry Potter references I'll do my top
five moments and then my review
everybody put your hands in the middle I
solemnly swear I'm up to no good
here we go number five pranks giving so
part of the episode was all about pranks
not just Fitz and Simmons pranking Skye
but about Melinda's hits playlist of
greatest pranks this did a really nice
job of lightening the tone of Melinda
May's otherwise dark past of
quote-unquote fixing things
it also kind of cysts the stage for the
possibility of future pranks between
shield members no matter how highly
educated or highly trained a team is
there is always pranks from the lowliest
of shield freshmen to the highest of
superheroes I totally bet that Tony
Stark is pranking the out of the
other Avengers the pranking subplot also
gives us our first Harry Potter
reference when Skye says stupid shield
Hogwarts number four post booty-call
mace
so Ward and may literally pick up right
at the scene of the crime
Ward comes up with this super elaborate
plot to throw the other member of the
shield team up in oh my god she just
walked off this means two things may is
one a very sneaky person but two she
really just doesn't care because if any
of the other team members questioned her
about it or made jokes she would just
stare at them until they peed their
pants number three May's speech to
Tobias in the barn so this kind of pays
off the Coulson subplot where we find
out what he said to her right after her
experience he basically tells Tobias
that the life he knew is over and the
person he was before all this bad stuff
happened he's basically dead so clinging
to that is actually the real hell at
this other awful dimension that he's
tethered to the speech is really intense
and it gives you an idea just how bad
things were for me after she took out
that entire cult number two the particle
accelerator so the team finds out that
it was basically the explosion that tore
whole and space time leaving Tobias kind
of tethered between these dimensions if
you read Marvel's New Avengers comic
book series especially the recent issues
they've been dealing a lot with the
multiverse so this is actually a little
bit of a crossover with the comic books
in the actual episode they make a
reference to Thor's Rainbow Bridge and
that the people that were behind the
particle accelerator might have been
trying to duplicate that technol
and my number one moment Scrabble or
should I say maze mischief managed not
only is it a nice Harry Potter reference
it also kind of lets us know that may is
doing okay she's obviously this
different person she gave that speech to
tobias so the person she was before she
killed all those cult members is dead
like she's gone and she's this new mae
person but there doesn't mean that you
can't laugh or booty call ward or prank
people so as dark as Mae is right now
she's not quite as broken as Closen
think she is but let me know in the
comments what were your top five moments
from the episode overall I really liked
it it was a nice May episode it almost
felt like her story was bigger than this
particle accelerator story let that be a
lesson in any Whedon show the characters
will always be a bigger story than the
comic book aspects even if it's the
other Whedon show I really love the
added prank to mention that the show has
now because it just opens things up to
have so much more fun all of the best
sci-fi and fantasy series of all time
have always had prank elements every
single Star Trek series supernatural
between Sam and Dean even Battlestar
Galactica had pranks and it was super
dark and depressing let me know what
your favorite prank is from a sci-fi or
fantasy show in the comments below right
now mine is actually from Harry Potter
in order of the Phoenix whenever the
Weasley twins basically went on a tear
and got kicked out of Hogwarts by
Dolores Umbridge she goes back in two
weeks on December 10th it's actually
bringing back J August Richards as a
super-powered SHIELD agent right now
learn all about the Thor crossover
episode last week by clicking here and
click here to learn all about the Doctor
Who Christmas special thank you so much
for watching
high five it's heavy pranks giving see
you guys tomorrow
you